welcome to this video playing anti-drone
so what's it the charlie cop or
something I don't know that was some
other guy I don't anti Jerome doesn't
have a name but someone I think told me
who that is forgot it though now
deadline that's the the old main line of
the south is some variation and I have
to say that I only know that other lines
because those are the ones that I
studied from the black side when I was
so still playing kings in Yelland
fianchetto green fields with black never
looked at this line really
maybe that's a bad idea ninety-five
looks kind of useful and now a 6b five
mmm yeah that playing quick moves is a
good idea but in lines may have no kind
of concepts probably probably can
backfire and here I really have no idea
no Bishop c6 maybe
hmm Bishop's is six Quincy too we should
be formed this is some kind of Perpetual
I mean a repetition not that he has to
do that he can of course just continue
to play I think black as comfortable him
i wonder if i should take on c5 next no
not now be two was hanging hmm yeah we
can do some kind of trading business yet
d takes you five queen bee to Queen 85 I
wonder it doesn't look so bad actually I
am I completely seeing this wrong 95
could be a problem 95
yes so hmm Jeff doesn't really look good
c3 is very weak maybe I can do this I
see just does he have something like we
need to or something something really
crazy this
it looked like a decent way to play here
I thought yeah and now i have things
like rube t7 eyes got 92 ok i didn't see
that one before whoopty to age have
something wow maybe I just drooped the
eighth I have Knight d4 though just
about 94 and there are all kinds of
tricks but i think i should do that so I
chick here and then 84 is strong how did
you calculate that so quickly I don't
know how people do that and probably
just a bad player ed for Luke see for
this is working
looks if I don't know Bishop like it
takes them okay but that is not that
much of a problem right what is the tech
on b7 I should be okay so i can take
here I mean I cannot take care i have to
take them and now can I go nite be 70 is
this insane not be 7e to cookie for
should work actually and some chicks
didn't plan that beforehand but
so this is nothing c6 may be okay after
push this anyway what's the point of
pretending to think i'm not thinking I
have to play that move in any case so
look F to King g1 and how does he stop
the C porn is going with this okay so
Luke evil so there's some way to know
keep this with Knight a5 or something no
night to d8 whereas we should we have
six not working time morning and maybe
here now the bishops III I wait Bishop's
III so okay I'm going going with King f3
taking taking this
need to get the night back to some chat
outpost can also do this 40 seconds
against fell behind on the clock after
with this with those complications so
it's a little bit more comfortable with
the bishop down even though I don't
think I should lose
I Kings you five is a good move
18 seconds
and Bishop e7 now probably losing the
age porn bishops are just better than
those kind of positions it's just like
that now yes I think miss played it
maybe it's still winning no we can take
aa stupid very stupid stuff now it's got
a night no what did you get a night
black forfeits okay this is the most
bizarre ending I've ever seen you got a
night what I don't I don't understand it
what oh my god is this what is this
actually is this lost I think it's lost
right oh is this a draw king of three is
drawn now anyway poor whatever we had
game here so we had all those wacky
complications Nigeria actually was
strong ever this looks very very normal
this however keeps it about equal rookie
89 to find you just 25 let's just like
that 93 takes takes its all given and by
the time by the engine with equality
just equal all the way to the forum
takes yeah you shouldn't get into this
problem adding endgame how do i clearly
draw here I think it should be possible
even though of course the bishop is a
bit better and yeah maybe 96 to King d3
was a bad decision okay I didn't have
much time anyway but here he is his
clothes he's really close to two winning
if not winning now it doesn't really
matter him turn to heaven to analyze it
just was too much influenced by the time
he got an eye it he key to good nights I
don't get it what is this ok anyway
thanks for watching